Pollsters started exploring views about
LGBT individuals, and attitudes toward
gay rights, about 50 years ago.
A lot has changed since then. Since 1977,
support for legal gay relations has
nearly doubled.
Support for gay marriage has increased
six-fold since 1988.
In 1977, 56% said gay people should have
equal job opportunities.
In 2019, 93% believed this.
26% in 1978 said that they would vote for
a qualified gay candidate for president.
In 2019, 76% said they would.
Why has public opinion changed? More
people know
someone who is openly gay than did 50
years ago, and familiarity
has meant far greater acceptance. Also, more
people believe that being gay is innate,
and they don't want to discriminate
against someone whose orientation can't
be changed.
Young people led the change in attitudes,
and today they are the most
accepting group of gay rights. As new
generations with more liberal attitudes
replace older ones,
acceptance will likely grow.
Is the United States ready to elect a
gay president? Let us know what you think
in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.